tha hello hello hello hello comment ça
va regardez regardez ce que j'ai
aujourd'hui j'ai cette espèce de grosse
boîte alors on pourrait se dire qu'est
ce que c'est que cette espèce de grosse
boîte c'est écrit ici rogue alan walker
c'est une collab qui a été fait entre
asus asus rog alors on va re situer très
rapidement rogge c'est la marque gaming
de asus et là ils ont fait une collab
avec un dj producteur extrêmement connue
kehal à nouveau le coeur et nous on se
porte un produit qui est pas piquée des
hannetons expression 1953 c'est un
ordinateur plutôt orienté casual gaming
mais surtout un espèce de deux petits
pas de connectés qui vous servira à
faire de la musique
et en plus de ça ils soignent beau style
chez asus vous avez une petite casquette
avec la signature rogge et alan ball
coeur et vous avez même des chaussettes
là est-ce qu'on est pas mal comme en
plus il commence à faire froid regardez
là au petit pied c'est vraiment vraiment
balèze qu'ils ont fait dans parce que
vous ouvrez vous avez votre pc et cette
boîte vous allez continuer à l'utiliser
et elle vous servir à deux pas de
musique alors ce qu'il faut faire c'est
prendre son pc vous venez le brancher en
usb c est en usb c'est de l'autre côté
et lorsque vous avez tous branchés déjà
vous avez de la lumière qui arrivent ici
en fait ça vous fait un petit sampler
[Musique]
et après vous avez différents effets
pourraient bien changer
c'est super
alors il ya un petit décalage alors ce
que vous mettez une musique etc
vous pouvez venir pitch est ici et après
vous mettez la musique de la walker vous
venez jouer par dessus voyez donc après
preuve c'est qu'un décalage pourrait
suivre le rythme on est complètement
décalé mais c'est rigolo c'est un petit
gadget si vous voulez venir faire un peu
de musique vous initié il ya une super
collab ici entre asus rog effet russes
g14 et puis alan wake up ici on est
vraiment dans l'idée de l'ultraportable
le zephyrus g14 il est super bien là
vous avez tous les animatrices qui vous
montrer dans quelques instants commence
à sa fiche on vous avait déjà montré son
ordinateur de l'année dernière ils ont
rajouté ce côté tissu la john de
république jean de gaulle klaus on l'a
vraiment là que le très bel accent rogue
alan walker j'aime beaucoup c'est
vraiment très très jolie machine et vous
avez en plus la signature qui va se
retrouver juste la republic of gamer que
l'attitude d'alain walker et là vous
avez le petit message fort noces ou au
dr même sur le dessous vous avez le
message rogue alan walker j'aime
beaucoup cette collaboration du mélange
entre l'univers du jeu vidéo le mélange
avec l'univers de la musique vous avez
un châssis de 14 pouces comme ce qu'on
avait l'année dernière ce machine qui
fait un kilo celle qui n'est pas
extrêmement lourde et en plus un truc
qui est très sympa lorsque vous voulez
l'ouvrir comme ça eh bien ça vient
surélevé en fait votre clavier ça va
servir pour la dissipation thermique
donc ça s'est très très bien et pour le
confort lorsque vous allez me retaper
parce que comme sale sur hélène et bien
on a les mains qui sont pas trois plats
mais légèrement surélevée vous avez
vraiment un très joli écran c'est les 14
pouces cdu qhd 2560 par michael sont
fixées du 16/9 une dalle antireflet qui
fait assez bien son taxi une dalle mate
sent qu'on sort des ces ip3 sindali psl
est certifié pantone et en plus de ça
elle a tout raflé schisme en 200 m donc
pour le gaming ça c'est bien et ça c'est
cool parce que vous êtes en qhd et 120
hertz les deux en même temps ça ça
marche vous avez expliqué le fonds dans
le rock fair use en g14 un peu là la
même confie d'ici on a deux tweeters de
0,7 qui sont planqués en fait juste ici
là sur la face avant inquiet là et
l'autre qui est là et vous avez ensuite
des haut parleurs de 2,5 pouces sont
planqués ici là regardez là et là vous
avez en plus du son en dolby atmos ce
que je vais venir reprocher c'est que le
son est un peu sur le médium ça manque
un peu de puissance ça je l'avais déjà
vue sur la précédente la chine ont ré
son ordinateur qui est plus orienté
gaming donc si on veut améliorer
l'expérience et notamment pour le gaming
mettre un casque tout comme le zéphyr
musique à tort de la dernière et si on
n'a pas une machine qui le foudre de
guerre on va tourner sur un processeur
d'amd c'est un reisen 9 5900 hs on est
huit heures essais sereine lui giga de
ram ddr cap qui intégrait et on peut
monter jusqu'à un terrain au niveau du
stockage en ssd carte graphique c'est
une geforce une rtx 30 50 pays où 3051
avec 4 gigas de mémoire dédiée au ddr 6
une machine qui sera convenablement il
va plus dans l'idée du cojeul gaming pas
du hardcore gaming ici on a une batterie
de 76 water vous avez un bloc de charge
de 180 watts et comme je vous l'avais
dit la vie d'anas un truc est vachement
intéressant et c'est drôle qu'il n'est
pas rajouté ici dans le rock est féru
g14 de l'année dernière vous n'aviez pas
de webcam et j'avais trouvé ça assez
surprenant de se dire ah ben tiens c'est
marrant on a un pc qui est orienté
gaming et quand on sait aujourd'hui tous
les enjeux qui lie à haut niveau du
télétravail et bien j'aurais pensé
qu'ils auraient rajouté un doigt calmes
parce qu'avant quand ils l'ont présenté
en janvier 2020 il bossait dessus depuis
un petit moment donc ça veut dire qu
avait pas eu toute la question du coc
vide et du télétravail et du boom du
télétravail ça reste toujours une très
belle machine clairement pas se mentir
mais sans webcam donc si vous voulez
télétravailler ou alors il va falloir
acheter une voix calme en plus ce point
du logiciel on est sur un windows 10,1
windows 10pro une dose dix familles ont
rien à voir une mise à niveau sur
windows et après le truc qui est
intéressant c'est toute l'expérience
logiciel qu'on est au niveau de asus
avec armorique wright parce que vous
avez un petit bouton ici dédié vous
appuyez dessus et ça vient ouvrir
armorique loïc et toute la partie
software ça je vous l'avais déjà montré
de quoi revenir à changer de mode entre
le mode silencieux
le mode performance il ya le mode turbo
le mode manuel vous avez toutes les
informations sur votre machine ici au
niveau de l' usage du cpu et du gpu et
compagnie après vous pouvez lire
paramétrer vos animatrix a aussi je vous
demande en quelques instants voulait
changer ici avec le mode audio vous avez
différents effets et puis vous avez des
effets de texte pouvait venir mais de
taper votre message ici ça donnera à
apparaître avec différentes polices
enfin c'est vachement cool et comme on
est ici sur une machine qui est dédié à
la musique eh bien regardez on peut
certes très rigolo on va se mettre quoi
la regarder la musique regarder ça c'est
dingue ça mais ça veut dire bouger en
fonction de la musique que vous allez
mettre en jeu sa absolument génial
sérieusement
alors pouvez venir les modulaires il y
en a plein regardez
bon ça c'est un peu moins évident à voir
c'est franchement hyper canon moi je
trouve ça hyper hyper beau et là dessus
ils ont fait un travail qui est vraiment
incroyable adapter ce animatrix à
l'univers de la musique tout ce qu'on
peut retrouver avec l'idée d'aller à
nouveau le coeur ici et on peut venir
après personnalisé modules et beaucoup
de choses en un bref je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment très très très très
très beau donc ça ce sont les modes
audio et vous avez également les effets
de textes et je fais apparaître un petit
texte coucou en plus qu'il y arriver là
donc je peux venir supprimés l'autre
effet si je le souhaite en même temps
pour ne laisser que mon effet de texte
alors si vous êtes didier si vous voulez
utiliser une machine comme ça pour venir
faire un 17 vous pouvez mettre des
effets visuels vous mettez ce que vous
voulez vous mettez des textes brefs soit
très très cool côté connectique on a
aussi ce qu'il faut avec une prise jack
3.5
vous avez votre port de charge qui est
juste là vous avez hdmi 2.0 vous avez un
vieux pc qui prend en charge le display
port le point des livres ing 5 et
l'autre côté vous avez deux usb a et 1
usb sesseli 3.2 il manquerait ça je vous
l'avais déjà dit sur les effets russe
g14 de la dernière un petit lecteur de
cartes sd qui aurait été intéressant
j'aime beaucoup le clavier je trouve
qu'il est une forme un petit peu évasés
sur l'intérieur et une fois de plus avec
ces logos alan walker qu'on va retrouver
sur le a est sûre le w les différentes
couleurs sont vraiment vraiment sympa
vous retrouve également le alan walker
sur la barre d'espacement et on va
retrouver ce qu'on avait sur louis xiv à
pouvoir changer vos mots d'ici là vous
êtes en mode performance vous switchez
en mode silencieux vous avez vos touches
de volume ou vielles coupé me creuser
par maurice white qui se détache juste
là ils ont vraiment très très bien
travaillé à son design de cette machine
elle est vraiment vraiment belle et un
clavier qui rétroéclairé également puis
le trackpad qui est aussi assez sympa
vous allez trouvèrent ce que j'avais dit
l'année dernière et je continue à le
dire sentez bien gagner un tout petit
peu ici un petit peu en hauteur pour
avoir un trackpad un poil plus grands on
a bien évidemment du wifi 6 le bluetooth
et du 5.2 et c'est une machine qui coûte
un peu moins de 2000 euros mais vraiment
un peu moins 1999 environ 99 centimes
c'est à dire qu'à un centime près vous
êtes à 2000 euros moi c'est une machine
de son matériel centre c'est pas une
machine qui sera là pour tout le monde
je vous dis pas de visio parce qu'il ya
pas de webcam c'est un peu un peu ballot
donc on peut avoir une notion de
productivité avec mais on va être limité
par ce manque de deux webcams ça reste
une machine sur lequel on peut faire un
peu de montage vidéo mais sans aller
trop loin parce qu'on n'a pas une config
qui est complètement dingue un peu
d'édition et de retouche photo également
c'est surtout une machine qui va être
orientés pour le coaching
si vous voulez jouer de temps en temps
si vous voulez une très belle machine
qui race etc et ip qui vous servira
également pour venir travailler pour la
productivité familiale bon je dirais un
professionnel vu le tempérament de cette
machine on est plus sur la productivité
familiale mais pour moi c'est une très
belle machine s'est pas ordinateur le
plus polyvalent du monde il est limité
je dis pas plus pour cette webcam qui
aujourd'hui est un frein en 2021 mais
qui reste vraiment super joli avec les
animatrices devant c'est hyper hyper
canon donc c'est une machine que j'aime
beaucoup et si elle vous intéresse je
mets le lien juste en bas dans la
description signé asus ne sera pas pour
tout le monde le ciel vous fait de
l'oeil si vous aimez cette config si
vous aimez ce design que vous aimez à la
new yorker ou pas elle est vraiment
hyper canon sursaut des bisous de
l'amour il a très vite vous embrasse sa
femme entame encore un enfant fin oui
[Musique]